I bought a friend off the Internet
people are selling imaginary friends on
eBay and I'm gonna buy one I didn't know
that imaginary friends were transferable
I thought you had to imagine it yourself
put in the work you get your friend they
are extremely expensive there's one
that's $600 there are two that are a
thousand dollars obviously it seems
weird to pay money for a friend
that's not how friendship is supposed to
work I just paid $20 to get a friend in
the mail so bad news my $20 friend never
came I'm worried that my friend is just
lost in the mail and that seems horrible
but in the meantime I really want a
friend so I went back on eBay and I
found a different friend
this one's $50 hopefully this friend
comes in the mail this time my friend is
here my friend is here this is the box
that I received in the mail welcome
friend there's something in here so
that's a little scary you know what
let's just open this box and meet my
brand-new friend whatever it is it's
wrapped in a paper towel I'm so scared
how is this a friend oh my god my $50
imaginary friend box included this
granny smith apple and an envelope maybe
this was food for the imaginary friend
in case they got hungry on the journey
let's open this envelope and get more
information my new friend is Andy Andy I
assume that you're in here so welcome
have a seat make yourself comfortable do
you mind being in this BuzzFeed video
it's a lot all at once I get that thank
you for your purchase he is an amazing
friend and he was always next to me when
I needed him I've talked to him and he
is very excited to meet you and see his
new home you know I didn't think about
that are you supposed to live with me
normally your friends don't necessarily
live with you and
you don't have a place to stay okay well
we'll talk about it you can definitely
sleep on my couch at least one night
we'll talk about it um this also says
that apples are Andy's favorite food so
that's interesting so you're from
California
Andy was just saying that it's weird to
travel through the mail which I totally
understand I'm so sorry
okay so Andy now that you're here uh
what do you want to do now we can do
whatever you want you don't know okay
um what do friends normally do I'm gonna
show Andy around and try to show them a
good time Andy if you love apples I have
to show you something Andy check this
out look at all these apples he's
excited he's gonna take like five apples
would you like to meet my new friend
yeah oh is it okay cool
Oh Andy hey good to meet you
where'd you guys meet on eBay yeah you
did not want to meet my friend hey Andy
I feel like immediately creeped out like
there is a friend there
this is some dark-sided [ __ ] I don't
want no part of this dark side get away
from me devil
hi Andy what do you like to do Andy and
he's pretty funny yeah I know he does
not like you though so Andy what do you
think of New York so far you miss
California that's fair I would do it's
very cool is there anything you've
always wanted to do in New York get more
apples okay we'll get you as many apples
as you want no we'll get you more apples
it's 9:00 it's my friend Andy is he
sitting in this seat right here yeah
he's right in here
oh hey Andy yeah Andy how you doing what
do you want to do now okay we don't have
to do everything together you know like
you're free to leave
you can go exploring on your own if you
want like please don't feel like you
have to be tethered to me oh okay you're
good okay you're going oh okay um see
see you later
Andy Andy I'm slightly concerned because
I can't find Andy he hasn't been here
for a while and I don't know where he
went and I'm afraid maybe he's mad at me
I don't know
have you seen Andy who's Andy Andy oh my
god wait indeed how your story we're
gonna go apple picking this weekend like
upstate yeah yeah what do you guys plan
a trip together yeah I mean you couldn't
come back you're back
yeah I just didn't seem like something
you'd be into okay let's just get on the
subway and head home you can go to bed
early if you want I'm pretty tired come
on in make yourself at home here's the
couch where you'll be sleeping can I get
you anything like a glass of water or
something oh crap I don't have any
apples I'm so sorry
would you a tomato no okay
okay Andy I got you a pillow and a
blanket so you can go to sleep let me
know if you're not warming
I just want you to know that I'm glad
that you're here and I'm glad you're my
friend and hopefully tomorrow we can
have a better day sweet dreams
what was that okay good night I feel a
little weird going to bed knowing that
Andy is sleeping in my living room but
I'm sure it's fine
good night what was that Andy is that
you Andy are you okay are you having
trouble sleeping okay I'll see you in
the morning I'm gonna go see if Andy's
awake Andy where is he
Andy where are you Andy Andy
Andy I think he left I don't know where
Andy went I hope he's okay I miss him
I'm grateful for the time we had
together however short the truth is real
friendship can't be purchased off the
internet this sounds like more like an
imaginary escort I would say wait
seriously yeah yeah you're paying for
his time so he's he's an escort yeah